a CBS News investigation reveals changes
police departments across the country
say they're making to confront possible
racial bias this Friday marks five years
since the death of Michael Brown the
unarmed black teenager was shot by a
white police officer who says Brown
attacked him in Ferguson Missouri there
were months of protests after Brown's
death and the grand jury decision not to
indict the officer involved outrage over
similar incidents in other cities led to
changes in police training but is it
working
Jeff Pegues begins our multi-part
investigation into policing in America
five years after Ferguson Jeff what did
you learn well we've reached out to more
than a hundred and fifty departments in
big cities nationwide at least 69
percent of them told us that they have
added training that teaches officers how
to manage unconscious biases that we all
have including race more than half of
those departments say that they've added
bias training since Ferguson but when we
asked if it works most say they don't
have a way to measure success some
officers even told us and it's made
their jobs tougher implicit bias
training has it worked you don't think
it works training itself the content was
an absolute string of around these are
current Mesa Arizona police officers
they are both white we agreed to hide
their faces and alter their voices so
that they can speak freely
this is their department's implicit bias
training so there's research that has
documented implicit biases and they've
linked it to ethnicity and race as one
they are taught how to recognize and
minimize negative impacts that hidden
biases can have on their jobs people are
inclined to stereotype black individuals
as more aggressive reinforcing the
minority of society that has that pointy
opinion about Caucasian males one of the
first videos introduced in a train once
we're farming that you're born a victim
if you're minority all right so what do
you think the agenda is reinforcing that
the police releases specifically white
male police a racist to our knowledge
these veteran officers have not been
involved in the kinds of high-profile
incidents that have divided the
community and led to what they see is an
overcorrection in new training fine
doesn't change what we have done that
has worked overwhelmingly effectively if
it becomes an officer safety issue
causing officers to second-guess
themselves was a complete change to when
we first started well there have been
some pretty high-profile incidents here
Robert Johnson getting knocked around
Gabriel Ramirez officers squeezed his
neck after he was handcuffed
Daniel shaver on his knees begging for
his life in a Mesa hotel room
caught on video there is nothing that
those officers did that was outside of
the training that they had received that
Robert Johnson video was that handling
the situation or was that excessive
force those handling situation the
officers involved in the Ramirez and
Johnson cases were not charged with
crimes officer Philip Brailsford was
fired and charged with murdering Daniel
shaver but was acquitted after a
six-week trial OJ's on the kamasutra
edge you understand me similar incidents
across the country have prompted calls
for police to change their approach a
CBS News survey of departments in
America's largest cities reveals part of
that response 75% of departments who
completed our survey told us that they
changed their training after
controversial use of force incidents 90
percent of departments who say they have
implicit bias training say it is
required of all officers but training
methods vary for example Honolulu Hawaii
told us that they have one half-hour
session a year Raleigh North Carolina
told us that they do at least eight
hours per year
I want our community to feel safe
despite what we heard from those Mesa
officers chief Ramon Batista told us
earlier this year that the new training
is working
I think evidenced by the fact that in
the last nine months we've reduced use
of
related events by over 30% points to the
fact that we're making progress but
there is no universal measure of success
other city departments we surveyed like
New York say reducing physical
altercations between officers and the
community doesn't necessarily mean
implicit bias training is working they
judged a book by its cover
departments in Hawaii Oregon Georgia and
Nebraska told us that they tracked bias
complaints against officers to determine
success but about 59% of departments who
responded to our follow-up questions say
that they don't have a way to know if
implicit bias training is working at all
these officers say some of the new
training is just for show they'd stuck
the video was saying we are not telling
you to do this at the beginning of the
session they say don't do this but you
got to watch it it kills him around
because to pay for this training we had
to give up something else right so
instead of doing more and I'm saying
okay now we've taken funds from there so
further officers on morale take a look
at it like you don't care about me and
you don't care about the citizens you
care about putting on this little show
Mesa PD denies the trainer's there tell
officers to ignore what they are
teaching as you heard those officers
believe claims of racism among law
enforcement are overblown but what about
cops who say more needs to be done in
our next hour we're gonna meet a st.
Louis officer who says that she thinks
that white supremacists are working on
the force there's clearly a big divide
here still there is there is and I don't
know if you could see it in that video
but as I was watching that you maybe you
saw my reaction my eyes sort of pop open
when they say it's a show when they say
you know we don't do what the trainers
tell us to do like you appreciate the
honesty and obviously they didn't want
to show their face but you look at the
Robert Johnson video and you go
he wasn't resisting your that's what
you're trained to do so I'd be curious
to know what should it look like yes
because I understand they're under an
incredible amount of pressure
but the point is the conversation has to
happen and it'd be interesting to hear
more about what they think should happen
in order to get to the place where
everybody's happy well exactly and we
were you know surprised by how candid
they were to and especially over those
incidents because if you talk to police
chiefs after incidents like that they
would not say what those officers told
us and that's why we feel that that
interview was so important because you
rarely hear officers on the beat being
that Pradas well we're really looking
forward to the next part in our next
hour Jeff thank you